[Música]
en nuestra sección de directo a nosotros
conectamos previamente con nuestra
corresponsal en iran catalina gómez
ángel ella es una de las periodistas de
nuestra cadena que se ha desplazado en
menos dos ocasiones para realizar un
extenso cubrimiento de lo que han sido
estos 100 días de guerra en ucrania
nosotros le preguntamos que en estos 100
días le echemos una mirada internacional
puesta en la región del donbass ella
estuvo allá recientemente y nos contó lo
que vio lo que vivió y por qué el
donbass es diferente a lo que ha
ocurrido en otras partes del país
también nos habló del costo humano de
esta guerra es que muchos sacrificios
para millones de ucranianos y también
nos resaltó este costo veamos lo que nos
dijo catalina comenzando
de todo el recorrido que alcanzamos a
hacer por ucrania definitivamente la
región del donbass es la más particular
por muchos motivos está en guerra desde
2014 si bien toda ucrania lo está estas
batallas y estas luchas contra la
invasión rusa se han venido librando en
esas dos grandes provincias de dónetsk y
de luján y esto se siente desde el mismo
momento que se accede hacia esta región
las vías de acceso son mucho más
difíciles menos desarrolladas que en el
resto de ucrania y este ambiente tan
pesado también se siente en las grandes
ciudades de esta región no solamente por
la guerra ya miles de personas las
habían abandonado desde el 2014 y en los
años posteriores sino también obviamente
desde la invasión el 24 de febrero pero
también es su naturaleza son regiones de
minería
metalúrgicas campesinas un ambiente
muchísimo más pesado sin embargo desde
que llegamos allí el 6 de mayo nos
quedábamos durante más de dos semanas
vimos como todo se iba deteriorando
especialmente en esta gran que unía la
ciudad de bach mud con lis y shanxi
severodonezk las dos ciudades que más
duro tuvieron en él y han tenido estos
enfrentamientos en las últimas semanas
vimos gente viviendo básicamente
cocinando con leña a la calle y sin
tener que comer uno de los factores que
ha marcado estas guerras como el país ha
ido quedando dividido desde el primer
momento de la invasión el 24 de febrero
pero también ha sido particular porque
nunca antes había estado tan unido como
en este momento sin embargo
por lo miles millones de familias han
quedado divididas en el primer viaje que
hicimos vimos miles de familias de
separándose mujeres y sus hijos dejando
el país en las fronteras veíamos como
los hombres las llevaban hasta allí las
despedían se veían llantos y cabo cada
uno de ellos se quedaba en el país
tratando de rehacer su vida y ayudando
para defender a su país a su manera en
este último viaje también vimos las
divisiones internas encontramos con
muchísimas familias que han tenido que
separarse dentro del mismo ucrania parte
de la familia se ha quedado en
territorios controlados por rusia y
otros han decidido o han logrado escapar
hacia ese a esas provincias que todavía
están en control del gobierno de kiev